you're watching the honeydew with Ryan
Sickler
[Music]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here at the honeydew Studios doing
it at Santa Monica Music Center I'm Ryan
Sickler Ryan Sickler on all social media
go to my website Ryan Sickler com sign
up for the newsletter be the first to
know all kinds of different information
hopefully when we're getting some live
dates all that stuff it'll be there and
make sure you are subscribed to the
YouTube channel youtube.com/ are Sickler
it'll be on all the posts everywhere on
social media make sure you're on the
Facebook fan page as well and patreon
keep sending your stories in email me at
honeydew podcast at gmail.com
if you think you have a story you'd like
to share we're gonna go through them and
have you guys all we've already done a
few episodes they've been a lot of fun
and that's the honeydew with you all
y'all you know I'm saying so send yours
send your stories in for that the
website for the show the honeydew
podcast.com make sure you're getting
your merch over there your shirt your
hoodies the night pants I mean night
pants nation y'all I can't wait to
introduce my next guest night pants
nation over here is growing and growing
so thank you for your support and I mean
I love I love seeing you guys out there
keep sending the pictures I'll keep
tagging you and I just want to give a
special shout out again to my friend
Lana and agretti here at the Santa
Monica Music Center where we record if
you live in LA and you're looking for
lessons for you or your kids they're
offering online lessons and this is the
spot man I'm talking they've been here
for 50 years they're a family-owned
business giving back to the community
and you know if all the uncertainty
they've done a lot of online classes so
if you go right now to the website Santa
Monica music com use code honeydew they
will waive the registration fee and give
you a free lesson when you sign up for a
package so it doesn't matter if you live
in I don't know Indianapolis if you want
you or your kids to be trained by some
really great Los Angeles musicians I'm
telling you this is the spot now that
said about the show if you're new here
welcome and for the rest of you come
thank you so much for supporting I
really appreciate everything you guys do
you know I mean it and like I always say
these are the the stories behind the
storytellers and we're highlighting the
lowlights and I cannot wait to rehire
over here ladies and gentlemen Josh wolf
y'all everybody what's up man back to
the honey burrito man I'm really good
I'm gonna show you how I'm doing all
right take a little sip of my water show
you my honeydew nightpain now I have to
tell you they are it's exactly that last
that's how I'm doing last time I was on
the honeydew we talked about night pain
it exists they didn't exist they did not
and we spoke afterwards and you said you
know what man I'm making some night
pants and I said go ahead dude I think I
said I don't think anybody else is
selling Knight basin to me I have been
for this goes back to I want to actually
say it might have been a santino episode
of the crab feast where I just cuz I've
always called him they pants Arsen and
they they start [ __ ] on me whatever
night pants night pants nah man I've
always said I want to do like night
pants I've talked about doing a night
pants tour where you come in your night
pants and then when you go home you're
[ __ ] ready to be there and on me wait
are you performing at night yeah [ __ ]
you because Loki that's the smartest
yeah because that means you just get to
wear your pajamas oh that's it and I'm
done I'm done I'm done for the night you
come out I don't know what
meet-and-greets gonna be like moving
forward but you know what I'm gonna have
available some fresh [ __ ] night
pants come get you some how many night
pants you go for a weekend how many
pairs of night pans you gonna bring for
the weekend because are you wearing the
same night pants onstage as you wearing
to bed no I'm going fresh night pants
every up every show every [ __ ] just like
a new pair of sneakers but I'm going
night pants
you know fresh night and do you sleep in
your night bag I do sleep in my night
pants if it's hot I sleep in short
yeah I'm thinking about making some nice
yeah I was gonna say you guys how do you
not have nice yours about the get of
upstate
right now I'm tell you right now night
pants of the same material
I don't hate those make them a little
loose with a drawstring these have a
drawstring in pockets any pockets I have
yours coming I'm upset that I couldn't
get them in time for you but I have a
pair of coming for you these are quality
knife man
I'm gonna tell you right now as many
people buying night pants you're gonna
have twice as many people buying night
shorts because a lot of people don't
like to sleep and get hot but they have
got a lot of Florida fans might need
some nice white shorts I got to
Panhandle I got yeah they want some
night shorts and I see so after saying
it's you and you clowning me yeah I was
like you know what [ __ ] it I finally
it's time I've been talking about doing
this [ __ ] forever let's just make these
night pants and then BOOM made the night
pants and then the goddamn virus hits
and there it is I got to cure for
comfort right there I told Sakura you
all went for safety with the masks I
went comfort yeah hit the virus from
both sigh smart you know it was really
smart the pants during the fur because I
will tell you about maybe a month into
quarantine
I said out loud let's see if those jeans
fit I have been wearing pants with a
drawstring for so long I had no jaw
I couldn't judge where I was at I'm not
gonna lie to you I put my jeans on and I
tried button that top button I was tight
all right yeah and the top button would
know yes so we haven't had a pair of
jeans on I don't know probably a few
days before quarantine because I like
this is it I'm done
yeah I'm not wearing jeans again unless
I [ __ ] have to from here on out it's
night pants and so I'm going old-school
Italian way dude I'm sweat suit rock and
underwear [ __ ] anymore all scales Oh
chiz you said ocean without where there
was a one it's like going over there to
I used to live near the guitarist Center
on Sunset mm-hmm
man there isn't a Russian dude there who
owns a tracksuit and
I like the way to kick my [ __ ] big
pills on that velour man I like it right
next to the idea the logo alright yeah
we have definitely have some things to
talk about before we do please promote
anything you want promote all of it
chaos all of it okay first of all if you
haven't gone to my youtube channel and
watch my stand up please do I'm the
special that I have on there there I'm
not proud of everything I've ever done
but I consider this to be a quality hour
in if you like story if you like
storytelling I don't think I'm the best
but I'm not the [ __ ] worst do you
know what I mean so I it's a great it
was a had somebody ask you this how many
YouTube subscribers do you have now
1.2 million yeah so yeah so but but go
check they're not pretty up there yeah I
do alright so the other thing is like I
do this show called control chaos and I
do it every Tuesday night and I used to
do it in studio and now because of
coalbed I do a zoom it's just so much
fun fun I honestly think it just needs a
couple of eyeballs and off it goes
because it's really just three funny
people riffing I give you ridiculous
questions to answer and it's like you
know it's honey for the bee you guys are
just get to do yeah do it is I wouldn't
even eat honeydew with honey on it
that's how bad there isn't I've never
taken a good bite of honeydew but
control chaos every Tuesday night and
then yeah just check my social out man
but those are the two things I'm really
pushing right now which social Josh wolf
calm Josh wolf comedy and also if you
like people watching people be high and
doing stupid [ __ ] every Monday night I
do in my backyard I do something called
the hi live where I take mushrooms and I
smoke weed and I turn on my guest rooms
also to talk about that so I do
mushrooms I take I do mushrooms ice weed
I turn on my camera I draw pictures
I read children's books it's just a lot
of weird fun and that's it man
just fun [ __ ] but I'm really decided I'm
not gonna do anything I don't like doing
anymore
I agreed agree a hundred percent agree
whatever the [ __ ] I want to do I'm doing
from now on I wanna hear
no yeah because the deal is if we look
at the people that we know who are the
most successful in our game that's
exactly what they did well so I don't
even mean that if I want to go get a
[ __ ] face tattoo I'm getting a flat
and face book but what I mean is what
I've learned from those people is hey
just be as much of yourself as you're
comfortable being is but the more you
you can be the now this is gonna sound
not the less you have to do as in the
less the you don't you have to do less
work but the less it feels like you're
working because when you're just it
always felt like work when you were
putting something on
but it's not if you're just being you
it's almost easier because you're not
thinking about like what Ben what do I
have to do to make these people I feel
like I'm gonna do this because this
makes me laugh and if it makes me laugh
the people who are watching or listening
that's obviously what they want to see
to but the more authentic you you can be
I've found from look at Joey Diaz dude
yo Joey Diaz this guy has done time he
is kidnapped someone yeah he is embraced
and loved I'm still buying his whole
story yeah I love that dude listen man
checking on you with phone calls phone
calls phone calls doesn't leave a
message now call me back yeah don't
[ __ ] text me you call me you text
them anyway maybe you get one reason we
made thank you there's a chest
you know his message on his used to be
on his phone hey you know this is
[ __ ] let me tell you something
don't leave a [ __ ] message unless
it's about work or you owe me money
anymore
this is autism this is Allah's machine
and he you [ __ ] talking about
sad so you want to come hang out or any
that [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] I'll [ __ ]
choke you next time I see it okay bye
be blessed hey but he would get so mad
so people would you know if you wanted
to mess with him you just gonna leave
him one message what's going on Joe
mother he but but he's how about this he
was told over and over again too dirty
changing you got a this is not it he was
50 when he hit 50 which means he threw
out very a lot of scary [ __ ] years
oh yeah of piecing together him in my
eye I used to be fascinated by him and
how he survived and and I remember him
in my kitchen we in my kitchens not the
right word but I had this living room
set that was all old barrels we had
found it on the side of the road in West
Hollywood and we were like Harold's
the barrel chairs a barrel table barrels
so and to see him sitting on one but he
would you would be like can you take out
this notebook any be like on Tuesday I'm
getting $20 from Rudy and you would see
him put together this week and you knew
there was an easier path for him and he
just was like this is who I this is just
who I am and eventually the town caught
up to it but but but that he was so
himself for so long before it was cool
to be yourself I think he's scared
people away oh no doubt won't remember
when I did your
CMT show they cut him out yeah it was
like he was there in the wide shots and
never said anything yeah yeah it was -
whatever for them I will tell you when I
did that show man the list of people
that I made I was like these people are
coming on the show the list of where
people were like are you sure that those
people for this crowd I'm like these are
my friends and a lot of these people are
my friends who everybody on TV says they
can't come on TV so you know whose TV
show they're coming on my [ __ ] do you
know what I mean like yeah but like but
but they were like they were like these
people they're not right for this
network well they're not right for the
network because they're my friends and
on this network that didn't always go it
did not some people got all the check
yeah they did cut them out man um so
here's the thing we go back a long way
obviously but I've known you over the
years to become a grandfather I've known
you but you've always been a father
since I've known you
always yeah and you told me that
recently you so how do you know 52 so
fifth I love it so at 50 and see I'm
just behind you but you're still growing
and learning and you said you just some
things hit you about your father
your dad you know um so my son is living
with me now and all what is he 22 23
great I have to tell you man it's like a
bonus time because that age you don't
expect to get this extended amount of
time when he has to be home so he asked
the [ __ ] talk to me he's good you
know I mean it's been the silver lining
from this whole thing because I'm man
let me just get tell you one thing the
silver lining is I'm so less worried
about not only do I get to spend time
with him and and and just hang with him
but the things that I was worried about
him
you know there was a movie a couple
years ago I think it was called 20th
century women and there was a line in
there I think Julianne Moore was the mom
I forget maybe not but there was a line
in there that their mom said to this
girl about who had taken her so his her
son out and she basically said what
maybe he was a nut betting she said what
what what's he like out there and their
girls like what do you mean and she said
well as the mom and the parent I never
get to see what they're like in the
world and I was like that's interesting
yeah you get to see what they're like as
a child but not a boyfriend or a student
or you know who they are in front of you
right at your house but you don't get to
see who they are out there because
everybody puts on their best brave his
face in front of their parents you don't
get to see like I know my parents don't
know everything but you know what I mean
things right right so that when I heard
that in the theater I was like wait I
was a holy [ __ ] but he told me some
stories about some [ __ ] he's done just
out in the world where I was like I'm so
glad you told me those man like I had
there's so many so many of the worries
that I had about you those stories what
you told me takes away those fears like
it was it's been so good to have him
home I'm I've always been confident who
he is you've met my son he's yeah well
[ __ ] you guys with him you and your wife
and and he changed my mind on ever
smoking weed with kids because I've
always thought I would never you know I
love ya
marijuana works for me I'm full support
of it you know this is water you know
but I always thought I won't smoke with
my kids I just always felt and also I've
always felt like it would come at like a
[ __ ] cookout or you know what I mean
really go to garage whatever but watch
my burger yeah yes sitting at a cafe I
never considered it being a legal thing
anyway in that equation sitting at a
cafe a real restaurant where I mean I
would go have a drink with my daughter
when she's 21 why wouldn't I do that in
a proper setting and that changed my
whole thoughts on oh well then I
probably would smoke weed with my kids
when they're of age yeah tomorrow listen
I get it for my daughter now she's five
that Elementary School's got a good
shift over there yeah that's why I like
public school man but think about this
like private schools coke and yeah
heroin you get public way healthier for
you well I I'm not gonna I wouldn't sit
and get bucked up either way I'm not
gonna sit and get your ruling drunk no
you know what I mean so like if you're
okay with having a beer a glass of wine
I'm not doing for football rips I'm
smoking a job that's it dude the
four-foot bone ribs I miss him so it's
been great
ha ha ha it's been great having him oh
and I watch and play video games on [ __ ]
and so I start to ask him for it the
first question that kind of I wanted to
know how his childhood was right I just
were like what was his experience I know
what my idea of what his experience was
well I'm just want to know like you
can't hurt my feelings now we're buddies
and like and then we were talking and
I'm the question that kind of kicked all
this off of my dad I asked him I said
where there was there ever a meal that
like when either me or your mom were
like we're having this tonight you guys
were like oh [ __ ] I mean everybody had
right growing up for meatloaf right was
it when we oh [ __ ] hate meatloaf and
I hate just like and did you just say
make it at the house I mean just like
meat potatoes and carrots they make it
at the house yeah and that's the thing
when you when they said that out all day
already Miller good [ __ ] bro my
lunch no we're having that for dinner
for me it was every Friday night
we were did not grow a lot of money and
so Friday was when my dad took
everything that was left over in the
fridge fridge [ __ ] he put it in a and
when this yellow in this yellow it
wasn't a crock-pot but it was a yellow
like pot with handles on the side and a
lid when he took this old yellow ceramic
pot out you knew his casserole night and
he put everything that was left over
from Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
and Friday put it in a pan put cheese on
that [ __ ] and called it gas roll so you
were like is that lasagna and potatoes
and green beans like it was everything
with cheese and he called a casserole so
I was telling Jacob I was like was there
ever anything and Jacob was like that's
funny about the casserole and I go yeah
that is funny and we were laughing about
it and then it when I start to think
back I was like but I remember how mad
made me a my dad growing up I remember
how mad I was at him and I remember how
I thought he was so [ __ ] cheap and
and like it was him how embarrassing the
cow how embarrassing even when it was
just us eating it how embarrassing it
was the feeling of oh oh my god and it
started to make me think about like and
Jacob asked me a lot of questions about
men you were different than a lot of the
parents that I knew in that you know you
never raised your voice and that's the
way ya hit it in there yeah I'm when I'm
high I'm more of a long vowel like I'll
hold on to my man or [ __ ] like that and
so it slows the guy but but I told him I
said you know I am I learned a lot from
my the way my dad parented me like I
remember there were definitely a lot of
things when I was growing up I was like
I'm not gonna be this I'm not gonna be
this and not hear this but I said this
the real thing that kind of changed me
as a dad was your first two weeks alive
when I realized that nobody knows what
the [ __ ] they're doing nobody nobody
knows what the [ __ ] they're doing so
mistakes are gonna be made first of all
mistakes are gonna be made also when you
have babies young sometimes you're not
emotionally equipped you know what
having a kid made me realize like I
would say things to my dad like I hate
you I can't imagine my kids saying that
to me
it hurt never had that no dude it hurts
me thinking about saying that to him
because I knew what that would do to me
if my if Jacob was ever like I [ __ ]
hate you too I think I told you the
story once a couple years ago when I
gave my dad laid into him a little bit
because he had
said to me if comedy doesn't work out
you should get into producing this after
the David Ortiz roast and I went off on
him and I had asked I saw him the next
day and I felt bad and I said hey I'm
really sorry but he also was the sage
that day and was like uh he said you
know I opened up a conversation to you I
asked you a couple questions you gave me
some answers that were true to you I
can't be mad at you for giving me
responses to what I brought it right
because it's not what I want to hear
yeah it was blew my mind I was like that
changes the chain by the way him saying
that to me that that day changed my life
moving forward because I stopped being
mad at people for their answers that I I
asked you a question man right well it's
not the one that I wanted but that's
where you all right but I would say
things to him that were just horrible
and what having Jacob made me realize
you know the two old my two oldest kids
were not my biologically and at the time
honestly the Jacob was born I was with
the mom and with the two kids I was
moving to California it was like in a
very and I'm a pretty easygoing dude but
you you see how life gets at you and you
can lose your temper quicker you can
raise your voice like all that stuff can
happen to the best person who is the
best parent who loves their kid more
than anybody do you know what I mean
there are gonna be times when life beats
your patience period as a child you
don't get that you know we were really
poor growing up my dad didn't have a job
for a long time I'm sure that was very
stressful on him he I'm sure that was
very difficult knowing that my mom went
to work every day this is not right now
when it's cool not so cool or not not
that I wasn't cool it just wasn't what
was happening right it wasn't ya Amin no
no no for the for the and it wasn't that
so he sunk and and as a human being I
look
now he was probably super depressed
because when he did get a job who he was
and his parenting this is what I all
realized later changed he became the dad
that none of my brothers got and I got
him for the my entire year high school
years maybe more but I realized that
most not all most most people are just
parenting the best they can know all do
you know that parents there's some well
you're right okay there's some shitty
ones who are not the best they can but
they're but that's the thing like and
you may judge the answer also it might
be the best yes there's a shitty penis
but like I really do believe that even
looking from the outside that's not
great I really believe them and so
changed my perspective on my dad and it
changed how I parented moving forwards
so much thing to about us as human
beings on this planet we take on so many
roles in our lives we our fathers
mothers sons daughters cousins nephews
co-workers [ __ ] did that you're not
going to be good at every single role in
your life you could be a kick-ass
teacher and a horrible [ __ ] parent
you know what I mean like well it can
happen you see people who are terrible
spouses and great friends in great pain
yes they're just not good at this right
just because you're a terrible husband
doesn't mean you're a horrible father
they're they're they're you're not you
separate that completely so usually the
woman's father but also that the
parenting thing is it's a long paint you
could be a great parent for eight years
and a shitty one for the next ten what
because you're the rebound but you know
what I mean it is an ever growing ever
changing ever flowing thing and
unfortunately it's the long game when
you get into your 30s 40s 50s where you
look and hat and become a parent look
back and go with four because most of us
grew up in a bigger fan your right
but also back then not diagnosing
depression anxiety let me walk it off
everything
duct tape yeah yeah I remember the UH
that the I talked to my dad about this
like because he was in Seattle where
Jake Jake was born and I was at the time
I had at Saint Bernard so we went out
and walked my st. Bernard you know this
thing with her by the way right massive
right they're all massive I mean they
could have a button barrel under there
okay so at one point in time I went on
vacation and my roommate didn't realize
that hey yeah it wasn't he had a little
dog he could put in the yard and not
latch the fence my dog's head could open
doors that had handles he was like this
that's it at high dude and he walk down
the street he got hit in the head by a
car
lived there holy [ __ ] lived hey but his
head got smaller's he was like a far
side character he had a huge body and a
tiny head really good yeah because
because all the muscle atrophies he has
tiny little head in this massive body it
was about a honeydew is dog yeah yeah
[ __ ] your head badly I won't talk about
but here's what he used to he looks like
this is when all the beethoven's were
coming out right so killer yeah so so so
dog kids would run up to a beggar make
up Beethoven right well after we got hit
in the head something happened to his
personality and he wasn't nice so these
kids would run up and bud was name would
lunge at him and so this one girl at the
park
ran up and lunged and spear for sweetie
was crying and the mom picked her up and
walk your way the mom I'm still walking
the dog around the park and I used to
tell him not bait over my bed don't slow
down slow down right because there's
only this dog dude as Mozart right yeah
this is Miles Davis I wouldn't come up
this dude listen 150 pounds I'm having
heart if he decides head down I'm going
that way you're going so I would kept
telling him back out back I'm back and
so the mom comes up to he finds me and
goes she's mad dude hands on hips
Karen walks right up to me and she goes
I hope you're happy and I'm like sorry
what she goes well you just your dog
just ruined all the Beethoven movies
like your well yeah she was like she
said I'm never watching Beethoven again
but I called my dad we're out walking my
dog I mean that my dad never walk on dog
and I said to my settle down I want
apologize here this is how long ago this
was this was two weeks after Jacob was
born okay till we see it through I said
I won't apologize to you and he said for
what I said it's not I just I didn't
know how much you didn't know and he
said about what I got parenting he goes
I still don't I still don't know and he
said I was like what do you mean he said
well as your kids get older you know
them less and less so they show you who
especially in this teenager they show
you who they a lot of times who they
think you want them to be so sometimes
you like one of my brothers would always
get gifts that he was like anything he
would tell us I hate that I'm like but
they think you like it
because this is who they think you are
right this is the best kids who are
liars tell their parents 70% of the
truth because 70 percent seems like an
awful lot to the parent well he did tell
us about that one thing but they're
holding on that 30% that you're never
gonna [ __ ] know you know and so
that's what he was saying is it doesn't
get easier you they're gone more you
know them less and that's you know it's
a great point because as they behave the
way they think maybe you want them to as
a teenager you're probably getting a lot
of that behavior to best behavior
especially if they don't live around you
guys are coming home for holidays and
things like that
let's put on let's have a good time and
his emphasis on making sure this is fun
and memorable and you know not just some
[ __ ] you know and I've talked about
this before but my daughter hid cutting
from us for year how do you know now how
well they're just parts of her body that
I never saw never saw a short sleeve
shirt so she would wear short sleeve
shirts but maybe the back of her leg
like hamstring and she would just wear
shorts or pants or right or in the
winter or when it was cold she would
always long-sleeve but that way she
could get her arms and like jeez you you
just don't know
and I'm people like how can you not know
I'm telling you right now I'm a pretty
attentive dude man I love my kids I'm
I'm in their [ __ ] I'm gonna do to tell
you right now if your parent and your
parent your kid is over 13 and you're
not snooping why the [ __ ] not
i I found out so much about their lives
there's only one thing I ever busted any
of them about and there was some [ __ ] I
found out that I was like I think this
is terrible but they're not going to
harm themselves or this is not something
I need to know I found when Jacob was 15
I found a vape with nicotine babe but
you smoke weed mother we smoked weed I
was like first of all don't hit my face
yeah youyou like I like that but I
wasn't I got and he was like you were
snooping I go first of all he goes
recently been in my room that's today's
cigarettes but yeah and I said first of
all first of all I was snooping in my
room you live in my house you are
technically renting that room every you
know that bedroom about that but he's
like you I'm like you're sleeping on my
bed in my room you're sitting on my
chair you're using my cover everything
in this house is mine including this
[ __ ] vape and I was like let me tell
you something right now hide it I said
and I even said to him look parents if
you're looking for something in a boy's
room look
an old cigar box some wood box that they
think is cool that they found on the
street somewhere you know what I mean
that's what Ashbaugh yeah this - box
look at so I said I might even say
anything about the weed you got in that
stupid wood cigar box on your desk and
he goes you found that I go that's where
you hid it
on top of your desk yeah found it dude I
found it by just walking in and opening
it up just I go just like the bong
that's in that paper bag out by the
recycling bin he goes you know that's
there to him I can why you why is it
outside bro he was like it's so big I'm
like bring it in someone's gonna steal
it dummy so he did he used to keep a
bong by the recycling bin outside
outside in a giant like you know the
didgeridoos yeah in like a case it
looked like a didgeridoo hoarder of it's
still stuck out yes so stupid because
you can't get them anyways but yeah I
snooped man and and I snooped and I wish
I had snooped and found out about the
cutting but but that's what you never
see only snooped on your son no i
snooped on her too you did but I didn't
find I found some things but nothing
right and in things that were just
private for her but like if I had seen
hey I'm cutting or I found a razor blade
I could have jumped in earlier I don't I
don't lot of people to be like you
break-in your kids trust okay but if
it's between break save their life and
[ __ ] you if it's but in when they get
older they will understand oh yeah you
might not thought they might talk to you
for 10 [ __ ] years you know they'll
get it
and if they died you would be like oh I
should have [ __ ] snooped I'm not in
there because I found out they drank
over the weekend I'm not in there
busting her because I found the clothes
that she hid that she wears when she
leaves the house that's all regular
teenage [ __ ] but if I'm finding a razor
blade or I'm finding like in a diary I'm
finding things about how I want to kill
myself
I'm glad i snooped I I don't when people
like you break a trust
alright I'm gonna I'm on the save life
side well I guess they're gonna have to
earn it back yeah
yeah man I just yeah for me so I
apologize to my dad and I was only after
I asked you when did you find out and
how did you find out if your daughter
hid it so well I'm curious to know how
did you find out she was cutting she
told us she told you she came clean
because she wanted help yeah I'm well we
had started to put her in therapy before
then so I think the therapist was like
you got to tell your parents so this
came but you were out of nowhere you had
no idea yeah yeah yeah so you and like I
said you always think you have a great
relationship with your kitten mm and you
probably do but there are things you
don't know when I hear parents say my
kid tells me everything
nope No would you tell your parents
everything [ __ ] no and I am happy yes
[Laughter]
that's the way fellas it but yeah so
having kid led to a lot of forgiveness
for my dad and an apology to him because
I knew man he said and it took this
thing looking back to realize that he
realized at some point he pulled oh my
god this is one of the hardest things I
had ever heard we were jar we were
driving to his cousin's house and it was
a silent car ride my brother and I had
[ __ ] had enough of my dad and how do
you at this time we were probably 10 in
12 and this [ __ ] guy just never gave
anyone a break and just seemed like the
biggest dick and before we were dad
nobody yes and just he just was always
on edge and never seemed happy but like
I said as a kid I don't know looking as
a grown up I know the dude went through
a tough period and a tough period with
four teenage boys in the house that's
going down do you know I mean like with
four boys in the house challenging
Authority at all times every time you
turn a coin
my else's telling you know yeah yeah
yeah every [ __ ] head it smells you
know bad it smells and constant fighting
I'm sure that he was like I so but he
pulled us over he look in the backseat
and my brother I never do I knew we were
just like and he maybe the first time
you know he didn't start saying I love
you until his dad died interesting yeah
always he when his dad roughly do you
know I bet chief like how old were you
20 years ago 25 years so it took him
years and years to say he wasn't saying
it you know he you know what he how he
showed he loved you as he showed up he
was at every game I ever played coached
most teams he showed up okay but he was
not I think that's more of a generation
thing to you know I'm not sure those old
dudes were kissing you on the cheek and
you know what I mean yeah but he showed
up and I didn't anybody was quiet
because he's just quiet dude so I never
gave him credit for that either until I
got older because I didn't realize how
hard it is to always show up to make
sure you're always available is all you
need to do to be a good parent show the
best you can and show up and be genuine
genuine genuinely interested in know
what they're doing if it's [ __ ]
soccer or whatever it is didn't be
behind it and support it they don't need
trips to [ __ ] Europe they don't need
that this is into that and the cars and
the fun that all they need yeah
unconditional love is it show up be
interested and love them that's it
these the my daughter you know I I took
her on a trip across the country to get
her first kiss right I tell you that
story get her first kiss so you just
said yeah yeah I heard that right yeah
you're driving your daughter to get her
first kiss I didn't tell you the story I
don't believe you have I just don't want
to forget your dad has just pulled over
and has turned around and looked at you
and we're gonna be leaving you're
leaving me on a cliffhanger right
yeah he starts to going to this stuff
you know his cousin is a really
successful guy he just pulls over and
what like it's work what briefing you
before you pull up where we're at the
foot of the driveway sunlen and it's two
cars my mom and my other two brothers I
don't know why were you taking two cars
a time it was just me my dad and my and
he pulls over and he's like hey so this
this and even apologize she's like I'm
sorry I've been real on edge and he said
this is what I want you guys to do in
life and he said a couple of things and
he said I want you to do those things
because I don't want you to end up like
me and I was like it was the first time
even as a kid I was like that was one of
the heaviest like when I look back at
all this stuff and I imagine saying that
to a kid that's how much he was
struggling it's just to hold it together
it seemed for a bit it was - it was
really you look back and you piece it
together and you're like oh yeah this
dude was really during a difficult time
doing the [ __ ] best he could yeah and
so when I started to put all that
together I knew I um whether he wanted
to hear it or not I needed him to know
that I was sorry that had given him such
a hard time in that all these
realizations were going to change how I
looked at parenting and how I reacted to
my kids and how they reacted to me even
if they were a little out of line or or
not to take things personally and like
there were so many lessons that I
learned from the the way he handled
themselves I have to say man graciously
they're the way I'd look back some of
the things that was said to him and some
of this is that I ate yeah some of the
things man he it was tough sometimes but
like I he didn't he did what he could
and man I look back like I said he
showed up to everything he was a good
dad he just did what the casserole
the way he could do it no Laura but just
like but that casserole you know what
else he used to do he used to leave big
because he wanted the burgers to be
healthy he used to put big chunks of
green pepper in him like Flintstone
right yeah why can't I just have a Sal
why I gotta have lucky why this is a
pepper have to be in the [ __ ] burger
I can't have a salad he was like nah
it's good it's right in there he was the
worst cook but was he used to make
pancakes for me and my friends every
Sunday morning in his underwear and it's
tidy why I thought it was your dad in
the military no it was dads make the
best breakfasts they just make good
break why don't arey dad's make it cuz
military dads me they're always up early
they make good breakfast I'm like dad's
a number anytime I spent the night some
I sound like a dad in military yeah my
we up for that always tidy ways my dad
was my dad my dad will come out on
purpose it's his house yeah he's gonna
come out of it guys tarnish it down and
and we're like Jesus Christ dad like
come on and they're all laugh and
everything and he's laugh and walk about
like my dad used to [ __ ] with the door
open that's you know that's claim [ __ ]
that's the thing I always said that is a
Power Move this visitor so one time my
friend I think it was Michael Connor he
was over at the house and we were
probably 10 or 11 and my dad was in his
room and he goes boys come in here come
in here and we run into his room and he
was actually in his room but on the
toilet and the door was open he was just
sitting on the toilet with his tighty
whities around the ankle and he just
looks at us and he goes what are you
doing today and I was like oh I don't
know
he's never never
that guy's never tell her that did you
did you have a meal that was meatloaf
growing up you hated it I hated meatloaf
I still I I'll say this there was
everyone at every time I had look you
got try mommy left no I [ __ ] don't
okay your meatloaf ain't [ __ ] either
okay your meatloaf ain't [ __ ]
okay everybody puts that same seasoning
and [ __ ] in it and what does it ruins it
I just don't think anything I don't like
the word loaf really in my loaf of bread
loaf of bread but something loaf like of
meat fruit loaf meat loaf of meat nut
loaf I don't need a low can we cut this
up make some hamburger patties yeah but
one time this black girl named Juanita
came to a Super Bowl party I threw and
she's like Ryan I know how you feel I go
listen to him and she's like I know she
was but I don't put I do it different
so I go to have it and she made a
football out of the loaf all right bacon
for the laces and then sour cream for
all the you know white yeah like the
border the football everything and I'm
gonna say this it's the only meat loaf
I've had that I liked it was it was good
but dude that's because it has bacon
exact area so I'm saying when you got to
start throwing bacon on honeydew and
[ __ ] like yeah and you don't have
anything you got good bacon I would tell
you this if you put bacon and sour cream
on almost anything that's a winner it's
a it's edible yeah that is a winner dude
yeah but yeah I mean I'm sure having a
kid changed how you thought you'd parent
right Oh everything man I and also like
my father died when I was 16 so as soon
as I had my dog like them I've said it
before the the ski most scared I've I've
been was the drive home from the
hospital mm-hmm like when they're fine
like hey this big safe building where we
have all the things to take care of
everybody and save their life needed
we're gonna give this to you and you're
gonna get that away from here and good
luck to all of you what the [ __ ] you
know it's and it was made me so nervous
to drive home but yeah it it changed
everything
you know my daughter said to me the
other day she had a
splinter and I've she's had a couple
before and I went to get the tweezers
and the last one in it hung it I went
all like it didn't want to go so she got
mad she was crying a little bit so she
did not want to do it on this one I go
let me just get it I'll make you feel
better and she looked at me she's like
dad it's my body if I don't want to take
the splinter out I don't want to take it
out and I look there I go you know what
it's a five year I was like you're a
hundred percent way it's your body if
you don't want to [ __ ] take it out
leave it in there
mm-hmm I was like it'll work it out cell
phone yeah an or later don't worry about
it but I was blown away that this child
at that age could reason with me and be
right you know she says a lot of things
and does a lot of things that blow me
away her memory is sick like is there
anything your dad did that you swore
you'd never do but you do I'll tell you
what I'd let me answer it the other way
what I don't do my mother when we were
little kids used to lick a [ __ ]
napkin and wipe our face I hate spit I
was like get the [ __ ] off my face yeah
you think it's cleaner now cuz you
licked your hand and wipe my face right
that's like the handkerchief licked the
thumb with when you used to see my
grandfather classy doing it but when he
took a handkerchief out blew it and then
put it back in his pocket I'm like you
nasty that's the one thing I wouldn't do
but my dad also had three kids so I get
it now
not nose run all the time like here I'm
like he just blew his boogies yeah and
you're putting that [ __ ] in your pocket
where your keys [ __ ]
[Applause]
so yes that I will never I've never done
that to my daughter like lick my [ __ ]
finger her mom does and I just every
time I see it I look at her I go yeah so
gross um but I'm pretty
I've only yelled one time in five and a
half years and that's not bad I raised
my voice and she cried she's like you
scared me and I was like well you know
what I wasn't right to yell and I
apologize for doing that but how many
times have I ever done that you saying
it's the first time like what you him a
lot I'll they just weren't listening to
their mom and I I was in the middle of
working on this studio and I just needed
to get away for an hour
a half or two hours to work and within
30 minutes I'm getting called because
they're not listening so I got to go
back and I was not happy yeah man go
back but that's the thing like did you
feel guilty about yelling no no no I
felt good and vindicate during the
pandemic it felt good to get some [ __ ]
out yeah
but also it wasn't that I felt bad cuz I
what I wasn't what I was saying was
being said loud
that's all the message wasn't hurtful or
you know disrespectful but my volume was
loud so that's what was but that's what
scared everybody so I didn't feel bad
about the message but I did apologize
for the the one releasing the holy you
have an ace-in-the-hole do you know that
the yelling gets people's attention now
if you if you overplay your car then
this sitting at the big whatever is yeah
yeah yeah but you can find every five
and a half years Oh twice and eleven
years I got that yeah if you only raise
your voice twice in 11 years I said yeah
I'd get my voice up a little bit I'm
like let's go I'm gonna I'll get one of
those but I don't [ __ ] I'm talking about
I came in hot you know right in the door
I was coming in later by [ __ ] you know
how many times did you practice the
speech and the way from here there was
no practice and I wanted a free float I
just even let the drag it out you know
you were talking about it in the car to
yourself though this [ __ ]
I was definitely saying some [ __ ] in the
car after I hung up that phone the best
part of that argument happened from the
time I hung up the phone with their mom
the second I walked in you feel good
that was a great therapy session that
whole ride huh well I'd say my ego
exists and mostly it's in the car that's
where I allow me and I'm like sitting
here we're going to no meeting don't
[ __ ] come in in this meeting ego sit
here in a car listen to music I will
tell you my car in the car is where I
get all the conversations out that I
want to have
I get them all out man and I just
anything I've want because sometimes man
when I want to say to somebody is what I
know is not the best thing to say don't
especially in this town in this business
so sometimes I will get in the car and I
will have the whole conversation I want
to have because I want to just say it
out loud mmm I'll get back to my house
you know what that almost is taking the
place of the list I'm good yes of course
I'm a realist of people yeah so but to
get it out
mm-hmm I just drive around and I say
exactly what I want to say how I want to
say it I get the responses that I want
to get because they are not yeah yeah
but it really and then they call and
you're like hey we're gonna push it off
to it's a god I was ready to go but you
know I never do is I never practiced the
conversation in the mirror I know some
people do I don't I don't want to see I
don't do that I want to I want to see
because sometimes I get just look I want
you to look at me yeah I want to see me
I sometimes I'm like is this cuz I get
lost in is that what I look like
how can I take my nose flares that why
can they see my nose hair like I can i I
did pull a gray nose hair yeah I mean
you're 50 bro you should have gray nose
what's the first one Wow
I didn't like it it's impressive really
do you get him
you got why you guess a 50 like that cuz
it's impressive
oh if yeah I know mom I get you know
yeah I get nose hairs I take a nose
trimmer though I don't know I don't
inspect the color of the hair when I
comes out of my nose but usually it's
dark usually it's done I know that's you
I know you do I like dude I like that
when I do like thinking yanker mountains
oh you know what the ones I like the
most isn't you pull on it and you can
feel it into your eyeball like you pull
on it and your eyeball goes to the side
I love it when you pull your nose your
nose hair and it's like a window shade
for your eyelid
and as I see okay it's attached I will
say this going back to your question of
parenting like I will not
I'm always goofy around my daughter yeah
I always play with her like we've been
swimming a shitload right now and I'm
telling you I've swam more already but
in the spring than I ever have in the
[ __ ] summer that's not true but we're
swimming a lot and I'm I gotta be in
there you know and it's sometimes I'm
like I just want to sit out here today
and relax like my shoulders killing me
like dad do I get in to be the dolphin
and then sooner or later I get in and
I'm the [ __ ] you dolphin time spent
that's it
and I it's what I say to like she's
gonna be ten and twenty in two seconds
and you're right it was really
interesting to hear your dad say you
don't get to know your you know him less
and less they become these parents and
you know employees or business owners or
or whatever they become and you're just
waiting on their calls or your reach yes
at them and they're about this they come
home when they tell you my boss is an
[ __ ] well we've been in the workplace
we know there's two sides of story
so we like my bozer but I'm sure the
boss would be like your kid shows up 15
minutes late right he's on his phone all
the time like yes
you know what I mean it has a smart
[ __ ] mouth like what are what is he
honest always in meetings like you are
only hearing that one part which sounds
super honest which I suppose is but you
like the other good thing is that Jacob
worked on the Spade show so I would get
reports back which was always super cool
I can't be like he just sent me a text
every now and then let me know what's
going on with that now I don't get to
see that with my two oldest kids which
is because my older son is in Texas and
my daughter is just 26 and we don't have
a eyeballs on her all the time and but
it is nice to hear that though I used to
be I used to love here and like other
parents would say about my stepson when
he'd come home heals mom they were like
hey he was very well-mannered and and
really respectful and it's like good
you're doing the right thing out there
that's nice to hear yeah but it is nice
to hear that as a parent I always tried
to tell people about their kids if
something good happened because I knew
how how
it felt but I've recently transferred
that over into my real life
you'll get text for me sometimes yeah
and I'll be like I just wanna you know
that I appreciate you and because I
think it's important man that we don't
do that enough with people in our lives
that we care about to be like hey man
just so you know thinking about you
today I think you're [ __ ] great guy
and I'm glad that we're friends look the
money thing is scary for everybody yeah
it is that not just individuals but
overall economy all of it and you're
right though when do we get to spend
time where you have to be home and I'm
heating it up like I said she'll be not
one to hang out with me in a handful of
years it's gonna happen we already see
it you know so to have not be able to go
on the road yeah sure
not the financial part is scary but I'm
I'm home with my daughter and hanging
out with my kids and having a good time
like invaluable wait and then why are
you doing it now well hopefully we don't
have to do yeah yeah yeah for real just
so you know it may be tough for you
they'll never forget this yeah one of
the things that came out of conversation
with Jacob and I was like what do you
remember about your childhood man and he
was like we had fun we always were
having fun we always you all i was
always about let's just make a memory
cuz i you don't remember everyday your
childhood there are certain things that
stick out so I was always like let's do
those things that are gonna stick out
right we obviously do the day to day but
we did and you know you do don't tell me
you don't have any money I well I didn't
have any money man when I was raising
those kids I've told you this before
yeah we did the our roller coaster was I
put them in the trunk of my car and I
drove around an empty parking lot
yeah right so but if you ask them
they're like that was so right [ __ ]
fun look I remember one time go on my
dad we went to Ocean City Maryland we
decide we're gonna go out we're gonna
throw some crab trap so you open money
now hell no are you hell no yeah we're
top them selling night pants
not some Bentley [ __ ] I'm not selling
Rolex is that so that's a lounge where
[Laughter]
are you from the East Coast Sigler's
yeah yes we are but we went to Ocean
City Maryland and again that's that was
a vacation for a lot of us like you
packed the family up you go to the beach
for a week yeah and it was a two-hour
ride right in your same state you know
it's not it's very different than
California which is much more of a day
trip to the beach place and you know out
is it's condos lying down the [ __ ]
whole coast yeah everybody's down there
to hang out and I don't remember I don't
remember anything about the trip I don't
remember this that and the other but I
remember we went to crab we skunked my
dad's like we're gonna buy some on the
way home we get a like a couple dozen
live ones and they're wet in a paper bag
give them to us and we're in an elevator
and my dad's like it's breaking and I go
I'm holding it no I I go it's breaking
my dad's like it's not breaking I'm like
dad it's breaking he's like how are you
I'm probably like 10 or 11 and there's
five or six other people in this
elevator I'm like no it's breaking he's
like right stop saying it's good you're
scared I'm like it's breaking and then I
don't want to get bit I'll let that
[ __ ] go crabs everywhere in LA
we're in come on I'll do to our floor
hits we hope we put they get out yelling
we're trying to we're all trying to grab
to get them back and [ __ ] that's what I
remember about that whole [ __ ] trip
memory that's what I remember yeah that
whole trip the [ __ ] up thing that
happened that was fun and fun you know
it's funny I've always said like you
don't remember how many times that your
mom or somebody cut the crusts off your
peanut butter I said what's none
[Laughter]
yeah you remember I remember but like
most people don't but you know I
remember the time my brother fell off
the roof right yeah cuz that was but but
so I my thing with with when I was
raising him was let's make some of those
man like let's I looked I also think
that for every good thing you do as a
parent there's a negative side sure yeah
if you like my youngest son man he can
go the flow easygoing what do you wanna
do today yeah I can do that you wanna do
that yeah I can do that he can talk to
anybody
give him some structure make him sit
down and do this this this every day he
it's not
he just is not equipped it's not how he
was raised so some people like yeah it's
great that he can go with anything I can
but have them sit at a desk for five
hours it's just nothing and the same
thing is true the opposite those people
who are very well structured and can do
everything and plan the day out tell him
dinner's at 6:45 and not six yeah
they're gonna lose their [ __ ] mind so
that's what I mean all when I started to
realize all that like people are just
doing what they think is the best they
can [ __ ] do it that's why I hate
those parenting books because to me the
parenting books are designed to make you
feel like a bad parent
like what my kid didn't walk in two
years old he's [ __ ] terrible kid yeah
your kid is a dumb [ __ ] okay
slow yes really slow Walker I would get
him into because you see people like in
the it's real competitive yeah who's
reading first in here and you know the
parent of whatever kid is reading first
a fun read yeah he reads he reads yeah
he reads yeah his name's also amethyst
so you [ __ ] them up
it's my birthstone like you [ __ ] him
up in more ways than one but but yeah
man that's why I got the books in lay
when people call and ask me for advice
cos for whatever reason they think I
know what I'm doing just because my kids
are all alive but like that's the goal
it isn't healthy but the truth of matter
is you can't parent every one of your
kids the same and who you are changes so
how you're gonna write is gonna change I
when you're a younger parent there are
things you don't care about that you do
care about when you're an older parent
like it just might be like my brother
was a dad at 54 the first time he's a
lot more he's a lot more nervous than I
was as a parent about her getting her
hurt or what can and can't do and as a
younger pair and I was like let's just
go [ __ ] whatever you know put you in
the trunk of a car and drive you drive
you around for a while right so like all
of there's so many variables I bet you
there are some people who had kids young
who were terrible parents maybe are not
involved with those kids lives got
remarried later and are better parents
cuz they're older and more mature to the
news the news yeah I agree do you know
what I mean like the [ __ ] it's it's such
a crazy thing like you said you're given
an alive thing and being like hey take
take care of this now what I don't know
I know that first time you get your baby
out of the bath and you're like are they
all this slippery right Abbi
whoo you don't know anything you know
nothing why is he peeing in my mouth you
don't know the dude and Yulin the the
thing the day that I realized what the
[ __ ] is going on it's getting Jacob out
of the back seat and he was in his car
seat and I looked at him I was like you
got poop on your neck buddy because when
there's the [ __ ] shoots up the back and
it like baby yeah it [ __ ] on his neck
got a chariot
and I look at my gosh [ __ ] on your
neckline and I was like do I not know
where his [ __ ] is like does he have a
second act that he did he grow a second
[ __ ] like and I was like mom was a
deal she goes no boys especially
sometimes it shoots up the back I'm like
up the back that green like what it Oh
green yeah I so funny as soon as you
said the color I just smell it
incidentally I was like but I secretly
have always wanted to [ __ ] that color
green
ah secretly we've always wanted to shut
up my back maybe not so eagerly I would
love the power1 we were gonna do we
worked on a TV show us okay you also
have to tell me about taking your
daughter to get her first kiss okay
across the country okay so we she I was
snooping and I found some messages I
didn't love online to this dude a lot of
talk about where people live and [ __ ]
and so as soon as I see we're exchanging
where we live I'm nervous because you
know who else lives in that house me
everybody
yeah yeah right so I need to know who
what the [ __ ] so we confront her and I'm
like who what's going on and she's like
I love him and he's old is she she's
probably 14 and I want I you know I love
this guy and and he's my soul mate and
right then I'm like hmm no he's not
basically we got into this [ __ ] about
like how when she's like how do you know
he's not I'm like Pete because it's
online and this is early online I'm like
you don't know nobody's there themselves
online she goes he's himself I go are
you when he responds to you do you just
write free flow or do you think about
what you want to say do you think about
what you want to say and she's like yeah
I go and this website you're on is for
cosplay and anime what's your avatar a
picture of you or is it like a sexy
anime character so are we being
ourselves how do I know what this dude
isn't some guy at the high school with
you know what I mean like what the [ __ ]
but she was adamant and I said okay and
he was in um he lived in Missouri and I
was getting ready to go do a show in
Missouri a with Larry the Cable Guy and
um so I was like you know what Beth my
wife I said I'm gonna take I'm gonna
take her we're gonna meet this guy and
I'm gonna prove to her that he's not
real oh my god
so that's out there right because not
because you know what dad's like as much
as their kids having fun and enjoying
themselves being right I was just about
to say being right oh man how badly do
you know how badly I was looking forward
to being right you know how I knew I was
gonna be right I go let me see a picture
of this guy because all I saw was the
avatar I go do you even know what he
looks like and she was yeah I send me a
picture so she printed it out do you
know the picture he sent he sent her
this is Lawrence Taylor dude sent her a
photoshopped picture you know like a
like kind of Art Deco doubt of 21 Jump
Street Johnny Depp so and she doesn't
[ __ ] know 21 Jump Street so he
probably is your age so she said to me
and he's so cute I'm like oh he he is
cute I'm like he's me this guy right
here
he's one of the best-looking people
who's ever walked Planet Earth and I'm
like I told Beth I'm like I feel very
confident let's take her on the way
there she tells me um and she's by the
way the plane trip she buys him these
chocolates I'm so excited to give these
salads and about an hour and she's
agamas gonna have one she's japako and
she was like he wouldn't mind if I bang
- right because - and there's two of us
and she had another one she was like you
know I'm just gonna split it with him
I'm gonna half and by the time we learn
is just like me
but on the plane when she's eating her
chocolates I'm super excited and so
chatty she tells me one of the reasons
is she's also excited to go she's never
been kissed before
and she wants him to be her first kiss
and now there's a lot of conflict for me
dude because I still want to be right
but this is such a it's a unique
experience for me to be able to be part
of the fact that she asked me she's I'm
with her and she's telling me this is
such a crazy thing for a daughter to say
to her father so I want to be right you
know what I mean but I know we're not
gonna run into Johnny Depp
so I'm instantly thinking if she gets
past the initial disappointment for
whatever [ __ ] doors is defeated Ellie
we might run amazing Johnny Depp not in
Poplar Bluff Missouri Yeah right
so she's holding up a picture of Johnny
Depp looking for him and I feel like
telling her he's not he's not gonna be
here let's let's lower the paper and
look for the what seems like it's gonna
fit because I know we've I've never
heard I'm coming with her I know he's
coming with his dad the stories in my
book so if you and it's a little more
extended in there but so I I'm looking
for who I think fits dad son looking
around also we're out in front of the
arena where I'm playing with Larry the
Cable Guy so we told him to come to the
show because the dad is a huge layer the
Cable Guy fan so shocker so yeah so I
see - father-son walking up and this kid
is not Johnny Depp he is the hey you
know when you see someone who's so pale
like the like heat like he stepped in a
pail a pale like like have you been in
under the ocean like that kind of like
the color of my legs you've seen mother
yeah so he's walking up with this
I'm like hey okay and he was Ronnie
death yeah it's close yes so it walks up
and he see he knows what Kate looks like
and he goes because he knows the picture
he sent man she sent a real one yeah cuz
she she cuz she doesn't look like an
underwater creature you know so she goes
Kate and I could see her go her face
just was like but I'm their first kiss
she doesn't want to admit to me that
she's right she's just like hey and they
real awkward and I shake this dude's
hand real nice dude I'm gonna give you
one distinguishing feature on it the dad
or the kid the dad okay
this is not a judgment on the man I'm
just telling you what I'm looking at it
doesn't matter he was dressed like all I
need to tell you is you know your front
eight teeth I'm familiar with rod TV
yeah so you probably never thought of
your front eight because you got them
all
my man had one condom and it was an
extra long front tooth that hung over
his little bottle of dude it looked like
that tooth ate all the other teeth you
know what I mean like there can only be
one it's right
one two yeah so it was long dude like
every all the calcium apparently when he
ate it went to that one too and the
other teeth are like kisses ah you just
with it withered away not even yes right
so I'm looking at this dude I see you
know the guy that shows up that's not
that's Ronnie Ronnie Depp so I got
ronnied up in this dude and Ronnie says
to me my dad is really excited to be
here this is Larry the Cable Guy as his
hero and there are almost 10 times the
amount of people in that arena in are
that I are in a hometown so this is like
a huge deal for us so thank you so much
name amount of teeth yeah so I we go in
there right up front the one good thing
I will tell you man
and I genuinely like the one thing that
bought this on a sidenote just to see
how happy this dude was was so cool it
also gave me such a great perspective on
like home just here to do it in the show
this was this was the biggest day of his
life he's getting treated like royalty
yeah way better than identity so so like
it was really things like that always
helped me with perspective like well I
have a pretty cool game yeah we do do
you know what I mean yeah remember yeah
what do you remember what it was like
so we had the show and they're sitting
front we go backstage this was a little
embarrassing when in backstage later the
Cable Guy is Dan Whitney he's got a
different accent
does he audit no I had that I thought
that was his act No
different action so he the guy walks
back and I got him in the green room
he's super excited to meet Larry the
Cable Guy and he says hey how I just got
one question big fan I've never thought
I'd be able to meet you and dance the
most gracious dude and he's like I'm
great thanks for coming to show the guys
I just got one question
how come you use your real accent on
stage and your fake one back here and
cable guy never took his eyes off of
them it just goes I'm sorry who brought
you yeah was like my fourth gig with
this dude I'm like hey man but we walk
out and so I'm like hey everybody I'd
like to treat for dinner let the kids
talk a little bit whatever you want to
eat this is third he goes I go whatever
you already eat and he goes whatever I
know whatever he goes I'd like to eat a
steak and I was thinking I'd like to
watch you eat it this is I think this is
a good idea right so we get in the car
and but when he said steak he was like I
saw there's a Steak and Shake I'm like
yeah whatever let's go take a shake you
want viewing Goods Daye yeah okay
top-notch all right so when we get in
the car I got to get all my jokes out
now do you know what I mean I gotta get
my daughters there I'm like so how do
you think he eats a steak do you think
his son choose it for him and then puts
it on his plate or does he say when you
how do you want your steak cooked
blended like whatever how do you think
he doesn't care does he floss with a
thimble does he just put it on so she's
like stop it I'm like how's it going she
said well we're not exactly soul mates
and I said you you still wonder this
first kiss
she's I kind of know I don't know yet I
go okay well we still got time we get to
the restaurant
the longer they're sitting together the
more they realize they're not soul mates
and we pay for the food and the dude is
super nice the kid is super nice just my
daughter this is it's Ronny Depp that's
not Johnny yeah and he's running out of
things to say because he can't think
about his responses for an hour or a day
before he gets back to her so nice
enough kid but never we're walking out
and I
say to her Kate do you want your first
kiss she's like well I go hey what
happens in Poplar Bluff stays in Poplar
Bluff I said but if you want to get the
nerves out of a first kiss until you
have your actual first kiss so you can
figure out a few things that you let's
just do it
she's let's get on it she was like you
think so I go do you want her she was
like I do I do I just want to get
actually cuz I came all this way I'm
thinking about so I catch them when
they're walking outside I go hey I'm
when we go back to the hotel and I was
like me you and I can sit in the lobby
and I told them I said there's a couple
chairs by the elevators you guys can go
sit there for like 15 minutes so they
walk over the chairs me and the dude
sitting hotel lobby this is the opening
line he goes you know my dad I ran over
me with a tractor when I was 8 and I was
like no I hope this last 15 minutes I'm
really interested in this yeah do you
know me will have to know that line
hooks me Oh 100% I'm done [ __ ] that they
can take an hour however long it takes
you to tell me this got one tooth yeah
and that's how you got one of them
wondering if the tractor cut that
[ __ ] mouth so my daughter they were
there for like three minutes my daughter
comes back she's like I'm ready gonna
I'm like everything right she goes yeah
I'm just ready and are you okay oh you
want say goodbye there you go she was
like she kind of scary after the
elevators they go okay I told the kid
nice to meet you son and you know and I
tell the dude he goes we should stay in
touch I'm like you know what hang out
with your daddy yeah let me know when
you eat the core when you enter the corn
on the cob championship and I'll get
there man so uh I go watching me some
quality fried butter in there
Oh God dad look at him the machine do
you want to know how he ate the steak
yes of course
he cut it into little pieces but he
mushed it on the top of his roof of his
mouth with his tongue he went on like
him pushed it against that tooth
I guess the tongue must have gotten so
strong you oughta maybe it's a muscle
mustn't it just kind of yeah and he
would just you team go I'm just kind of
I was like that is the [ __ ] so we go
back we get in the elevator where you go
up to the room we get in the hotel room
me and her and I'm in my bed and she's
getting ready hasn't said a word about
it and I'm pretending to watch TV and
she sits and on her bed and starts to
watch TV and I turn TV if I go wait a
second all of that we make the plan
first kiss you know you didn't tell me
anything she goes alright what I don't
want to talk about it after this I go
okay she was we were sitting there and I
had I realized he had never been kissed
before either it was both our first kiss
and I went to lean in and we leaned in
too fast and he he had had a giant
pimple on his chin I thought you don't
say he had have one big bottom no no he
had one giant pimple and when they they
live too hard and her face popped his
pimple no and it squirted on her face it
exploded right so now all that is sick
gross you know me man I'm trying not to
laugh and I'm also trying not to slap
myself on the back for being right but
I'm also feel bad for my daughter you
know what I mean but it was the craziest
I learned by the way that trip you know
what I learned
she points a lot of things out to me
about the way I parented her she because
she did a lot of cosplay and anime and I
mean on humor when I don't know things
or understanding what makes fun of it
yes and I set them to her about and she
goes yeah but you don't care about that
I go what do you mean I listen to
everything you say and she goes yeah but
you call it
you never pronounce it right as a joke
and you're always making some sort of
joke and but you never naked
about Jacob when he talked about
baseball or I go yeah but I understand
baseball she was well then why don't you
just learn something about what I'm
doing put this sexy pan yeah
put these elven ears on but like but she
says she goes I know you think you're
there but you're not present you're not
there when I'm talking to you because
you don't care about what it is that I'm
doing I said I care she goes yeah but
not enough to find out what it is or
listen and you make a joke because you
don't know what I'm talking about and
that doesn't make it weird that just
means that you haven't taken the time to
figure out what I do and I was like yup
yep yep yep yep but she was a hundred
percent right but it was a great chip on
so many levels like I learned so much
about her I did learn a lot about myself
I was right it ended up being a great
story she come in for you to tell ya
well listen you know what I'm not so
concerned with that because at the end
of the day man even though I wanted it
to be and she obviously had a great real
first kiss and all this stuff but the
end of the day she deleted that account
and she's even said to this day she was
like yeah I don't believe anything I
read on there from anybody
which if it took one broken pebble Hey
job well done Danny you gotta end this
and you got to break a couple pimples
along the way you know what I mean
someone else's face oh god that's it did
you ever date anybody like the pop
pimples on your body yeah I love those
girls oh oh no I mean I would ask them
like can you get that one on my back I
can't get maybe you know they all play
aesthetician or whatever dermatologist
and get all up on they go look you ever
get one trying to do you think I got to
get those blackheads out of your nose no
not on my face no but on my on my back
or something like that hell yeah
you ever a little girl pee for you when
you're standing up hold it yeah yeah I
couldn't do it I've let them and I've
also asked them to help me out with this
is about to piss my pants I'm shit-faced
I can't get my dick out of my night pass
or if we get a selfie
if you could just help me laid out on
the side I pull my dick through my nine
hole pants right here it's a night hole
in my night man do you have your night
pants at home yeah yeah I need to see it
wait do they no they don't they're
better you can wear them without
underwear but you shouldn't around kids
no that's all yeah especially other
people's kids
well dude thank you so much for coming
on this has been [ __ ] awesome I can't
believe you'd never heard that story
dude how much your hat I don't think
I've ever heard that I mean we've done
so many together I mean hell it sounded
new to me I feel like I remember
something I saw one [ __ ] and a
pimple pop on someone else's face yeah
no man you know what I'll tell you
something you are and I listen to your
podcast because you get I don't know
what it is about you but you get great
things out of your guests thanks people
I guess you're easy to talk to that's
nice ah you have the I think it's from
obviously from doing it so long crap
fees but you know the perfect time to
jump in my jokes like you I appreciate
that I'm flattered I'm safe from you to
me yeah you really you try to keep that
darkness a little bit low yeah but you
can't you pick the Snipe spot especially
you're like okay the the low the
darkness has happened for just long
enough I'm on it
I'll [ __ ] on this guy thank you brother
yeah I do it's really impressive
well I appreciate you you know like I
said either you're a great father and
you write I mean I'm 47 I'll be
different in three years and parent
different and think differently and
every day at all changes and my
daughter's not gonna be five she'll be
eight so then you got a she's doing
different shits your kid is a teenager
yeah God one of one's gonna be like when
they're [ __ ] parents I just want to
sit back and laugh at him good luck with
that [ __ ] my pants do the fly good luck
yeah that's my parents my parents like
you know we never had to deal with the
Internet mm-hmm enjoy that yeah yeah do
one more time please promote everything
you'd like control chaos
Tuesdays 7 o'clock Pacific time
it's a half an hour just fun and I get
some pretty big guests on there we have
Brian on the other day the guys from
NSYNC you Tiffany Haddish was on this
week and then I do a hi live Monday
night on my Facebook fan page at 7
o'clock it's just me getting really high
taking mushrooms and reading children's
books and doing weird [ __ ] and then just
check out my youtube channel if you
haven't there's some fun comedy on there
I love it brother I love you too
get the bank you for coming you're
always welcome and thank you all as well
Ryan Sickler on all social media Ryan
Sickler com go subscribe to the YouTube
channel now we'll talk to y'all next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you